zur behandlung nach deutschland russland
lässt alexander wallende jetzt doch aus
fliegender oppositionelle soll vergiftet
worden sein und liegt immer noch im koma
kampfansage an donald trump der
demokratische präsidentschaftskandidat
job beiden erklärt die us wahl zur
entscheidung zwischen licht und
finsternis und erste bilanz an deutschen
schulen ob und wie der korona alltag
dort funktioniert das bewerten politik
und gewerkschaften ganz unterschiedlich
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieber der begrüßt sie sehr
herzlich guten abend zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
hochsommerlichen freitag sport nachher
in der sendung mit kristin otto genau
zwei tage vor dem champions league
finale genannt
wir beginnen mit dem schicksal von
alexei navalny dem russischen anti
korruptions aktivisten und gegner von
präsident putin
sein schicksal ist jetzt in der hand
deutscher ärzte navalny darf nach
deutschland ausgeflogen werden er liegt
derzeit im koma auf der intensivstation
eines krankenhauses in sibirien navis
fall von anfang an höchst mysteriös und
das bleibt er auch heute navis
mitstreiter sind sich sicher
er sei vergiftet wurden die russischen
ärzte sehen dafür keine anzeichen
christiansen berichtet aus moskau
während alexej nawalny hier ums
überleben kämpft kämpft sein team den
ganzen tag dafür dass der kreml kritiker
zur behandlung nach deutschland geflogen
wird
doch die ärzte weigern sich lehnen immer
wieder ab navalny zustand sei zu
instabil heißt es vor einer stunde dann
ein sinneswandel
wir sind den wünschen der verwandten
nachgekommen und haben den transport
genehmigt mit dieser spezialmaschine
sollen je nach berlin geflogen werden an
bord deutsche ärzte sein team und
ehefrau julia beschuldigten die behörden
den transport hinaus gezögert zu haben
sie machen das um zeit zu gewinnen damit
die chemische substanz in alexis körper
verschwindet er ist in keiner guten
verfassung und natürlich trauen wir dem
krankenhaus nicht in einem brief
forderte juliana wallmeier präsident
putin persönlich auf den transport zu
erlauben
aus dem kreml hieß es die entscheidung
liege allein bei den zuständigen ärzten
die sagen hinweise auf eine vergiftung
gebe es nicht gefunden worden sei aber
eine chemische industrielle substanz auf
navalny haaren und händen
gemessen an der tatsache dass keine
gifte in seinem blut oder andere
biologische materialien gefunden wurden
denken wir dass er eine
stoffwechselstörung hat die den
blutzuckerspiegel aufgrund einer
schnellen druck änderungen im flugzeug
senkt um genau zu sein
wir denken es war während des starts die
deutschen mediziner hatten navalny am
nachmittag besucht versuche des navalny
teams mit ihnen zu reden wurden
verhindert jetzt aber scheint der weg
frei und ärzte in deutschland werden um
neuwahlen ins leben kämpfen gibt es noch
einige fragen beginnen wir mit christian
slam in moskau christian guten abend was
dürfte jetzt den ausschlag gegeben haben
dass nach wollen die doch noch
deutschland darf ja na wann ist ihm die
haben ja den ganzen tag dafür gekämpft
dass das noch möglich wird das navi in
deutschland behandelt werden kann
das hatte vor allem den grund dass frau
hat das ja heute auch noch mal betont
dass er dem krankenhaus nicht vertrauen
das ihr den ärzten nicht vertrauen und
von einer behandlung in deutschland
erhoffen sie sich unabhängige ärzte
bessere medizinische versorgung und
vielleicht sogar die tatsache dass wenn
es einen giftstoff im körper gab von
alexander wenig dass der noch irgendwie
identifiziert werden kann
was heute jetzt ausschlaggebend war dass
das doch noch geklappt hat nachdem die
ärzte gemacht haben
das wissen wir im moment noch nicht aber
der kreml hat das zumindest nicht
verhindert
jetzt ist das zunächst mal ein mensch
dem in höchster not geholfen wird aber
dann natürlich kein normaler patient
theo was heißt denn das für das
verhältnis moskau berlin
nun ich glaube das wird das verhältnis
natürlich belasten aber putins interesse
an der sache dürfte höherrangig seien
die ausreise dürfte ja nicht ohne seine
ausdrückliche zustimmung erfolgt seien
und das heißt putin ist einverstanden
erster ist damit sein schärfster und
wichtigster kritiker außer landes und
wird es vielleicht auch bleiben und mit
blick auf die erhebung in belarus ist es
ein weithin sichtbares signal an die
eigene bevölkerung und an die opposition
so kann es euch ergehen wenn ihr gegen
mich seit das ist dann von deutschen
ärzten vielleicht sogar noch einen
objektiven
medizinischen befund geben wird das
heißt also ob es wirklich gift oder eine
andere gefährliche substanz war das
dürfte die klarheit dieser botschaft
dann nur noch unterstreichen also alles
im sinne des machterhalt von putin hat
sich dank für diese einschätzungen nach
berlin und moskau und so fiel zunächst
zu diesem thema jetzt das nächste in
dieser sendung
es war wohl die wichtigste rede seines
lebens und manche beobachter sagen auch
die beste joe biden will us-präsident
werden er will donald trump ablösen
und so hat er sich dem virtuellen
parteitag der demokraten vergangene
nacht präsentiert und vor allem den
wählerinnen und wählern in den usa
joe biden zeigt sich als einer der das
tief gespaltene land wieder versöhnen
könne er sehr ein anderes amerika eines
das großzügig sei und stark in seiner
parteitagsrede sprach beiden zehnmal von
hoffnung elf mal vom licht und nur
fünfmal von furcht die us-medien haben
da genau mitgezählt über die rede von
joe biden jetzt britta jäger
scheinwerfer an für joe biden auf seinen
auftritt haben alle gewartet zum finale
des virtuellen parteitags der demokraten
umreißt der tramp herausforderer
entschlossen seine vision von amerika
und bietet ein kontrastprogramm zum
aktuellen amtsinhaber der jetzige
präsident hat amerika viel zu lange in
dunkelheit gehüllt zu viel wut zu viel
angst zu viel spalte ich gebe ihnen mein
wort wenn sie mal die präsidentschaft an
vertrauen werde ich auf das beste von
uns zurückgreifen und nicht auf das
schlechteste in einem video werben
beiden kinder emotional für ihren vater
der erst seine erste frau und tochter
bei einem autounfall verliert später
stirbt sein ältester sohn beau an einem
gehirntumor
er gibt sich als familienmensch als
kümmerer als krisenmanager im
vorwahlkampf wirkte der 77-jährige
beiden manchmal fahre ich unsicher die
zweifel an seiner fitness will er nun
endgültig ausräumen
selbstbewusst verspricht er der
präsident aller
ricaner zu sein und die wirtschaft
wieder aufzubauen im kampf gegen korona
will er eine nationale masken pflicht
durchsetzen beiden wettert gegen
amtsinhaber chung dieser präsident hat
in seiner grundlegenden pflicht
gegenüber der nation versagt er hat uns
nicht beschützt
als präsident werde ich ihnen
versprechen ich werde amerika beschützen
vor jeder sichtbaren und unsichtbaren
attacke immer beiden setzt seine
ausrufezeichen zum abschluss eines
ungewöhnlichen parteitages der
startschuss in die heiße phase des
wahlkampfes bringen wir uns in amerika
korrespondenten mit dazu hier in die
sendung
elmer es überrascht ja nicht mehr so
wahnsinnig viel in amerikanischer
politik aber fragt immer so einen
kleinen schritt zurück da stellt sich
heute nacht einer hin und stellt das
ganze da als kampf gut gegen böse viel
höher kann man es ja nicht mehr hängen
welche strategie steckt dahinter also
das klingt natürlich extrem
melodramatisch aber für viele amerikaner
fühlt sich das gerade eben so an
dramatik sie bangen um ihre existenz um
ihre jobs ihre unterkünfte ihre
versorgung ihre gesundheit und solche
einfachen amerikaner sind bei diesem
parteitag aufgetreten und haben erzählt
davon dass joe biden ihnen zugehört habe
dass er etwas für sie getan habe dass er
ein mann sei der das hält was er
verspricht und joe biden hat dann in
seiner rede eben auch eine ganze menge
konkret versprochen
zum beispiel eben den kampf gegen den
klimawandel den kampf gegen den
rassismus steuererhöhungen für reiche
und vieles mehr
und das ist der weg gewesen jetzt wie er
die partei vereint hat und ich glaube
dass ich ihm ganz klar gelungen
wie sehr hat den beiden damit donald
trump unter druck gesetzt also kann man
absehen wie der reagieren wird auf
seinem parteitag also donald trump wird
joe biden weiterhin als radikalen linken
bezeichnen der unter dessen
präsidentschaft an das land im chaos und
der gewalt versinken würde dann zwar
wird sicherlich auch eine ganz große
steuersenkung ankündigen vielen
gesteuert geschenke quasi versprechen
aber er steht unter dem druck auch ganz
konkrete konzepte gegen die krisen
vorzulegen
wenn er das nicht tut spielt er dem
narrativ der demokraten in die hände
dass es am dritten november tatsächlich
um gut gegen böse licht gegen die
dunkelheit geht
herzlichen dank für diese erläuterungen
live aus milwaukee und damit nach
deutschland andreas kalbitz bleibt
vorerst aus der afc ausgeschlossen
das berliner landgericht wies seinen
antrag auf erlass einer einstweiligen
verfügung zurück der frühere
brandenburger landeschef kündigte an
weiter juristisch für seine
parteimitgliedschaft zu kämpfen
was das für die afg bedeutet zeigt jetzt
nicole diekmann andreas kalbitz selbst
erschien nicht vor gericht seine
unterstützer jedoch trommelten auch
heute morgen noch für ihn das urteil
aber lautet kein witz bleibt
ausgeschlossen
ein mitglied des parteivorstands zeigte
sich erleichtert allerdings geht der
streit jetzt in die nächste runde
der afg ehrenvorsitzende alexander
gauland gerät zunehmend unter druck
bauland der sich große verdienste für
die afd erworben hat hat in den letzten
tagen und wochen mehrfach unglücklich
agiert weitergehend werde ich jetzt aber
nichts dazu sagen wir werden uns damit
aber denke ich auch im bundesvorstand
beschäftigt land hatte sich bis zum
schluss für kallwitz den der
verfassungsschutz als rechtsextremisten
einstuft eingesetzt nun geht der streit
also weiter und zwar innerhalb des
parteivorstands fraktionschefin alles
beide die gegen credits ausschluss
gestimmt hatte teilte heute mit
für die partei ist längst ein schaden
eingetreten es zeigt sich dass es wie
ich es im bundesvorstand beantragt hatte
besser gewesen wäre die causa kids
zunächst intern juristisch zu prüfen
das hätte der partei viel ärger erspart
das geht gegen ihn
parteichef jack morton er war die
treibende kraft hinter dem ausschuss von
kallwitz auf vinyl übersieht dabei wie
übrigens bei bauland und einige andere
dass wir das intern sehr sorgfältig
vorab geprüft haben und ich fände es gut
wenn sie sich eingestehen wurden das
wir einfach recht gehabt haben keilwitz
könnte noch ein sogenanntes hauptsache
verfahren anstreben
allerdings rücken immer mehr politische
unterstützer von ihm ab sein
fraktionskollege nach einem angeblich
freundschaftlichen boxschlag von kibiz
mit mails riss ins krankenhaus musste
juristisch mag das letzte wort in der
causa kallwitz also noch nicht
gesprochen sein
politisch aber scheint der brandenburger
erledigt und jetzt in der sendung gucken
wir auf die korona situation in europa
steigen die infektionszahlen wieder an
trotzdem sei die situation in
europäischen ländern auch ohne zweiten
lockdown in den griff zu bekommen sagt
die whu man habe mittlerweile viel über
den umgang mit dem virus gelernt die
zahlen für deutschland das robert koch
institut registrierte 1427 neue fälle
innerhalb eines tages im schnitt der
vergangenen woche wurden täglich 1290
neuinfektionen gemeldet gestern lag die
zahl noch bei 1260 nächsten donnerstag
will bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
übrigens mit den ministerpräsidenten der
länder über das weitere vorgehen bei der
korona bekämpfung geräten ein thema aber
dem treffen dann sicher auch der neue
hygiene alltag in deutschen schulen
wieder erläuft haben drei schipanski und
hannah hebestreit beobachtet
der ernst des lebens strickmaske wie
hier in taunusstein gilt auch für die
kleinsten wer zur schule kommt ist zum
tragen verpflichtet die meinung bei ihr
eindeutig tragen aber lösen zu anderen
klassen und sonst überall und masken
tragen für hessen gilt auf dem
schulgelände masken pflicht nicht aber
im unterricht gerade für grundschüler
aus sicht der eltern wichtig ich finds
gut für die erstklässler denn lesen und
schreiben lernt kommt über die mimik und
über die mundbewegungen das wäre ein
problem für die kinder gewesen wenn die
maske auf einen klassenraum getragen
offenbach aber musste heute die
notbremse ziehen wegen zu hohen
infektionszahlen in der stadt gilt hier
auch im unterricht masken pflicht
dadurch dass offenbar eine multi kulti
stadt ist und die meisten familien
daneben in ihren heimatländern urlaub
gemacht haben
es ist durchaus verständlich dass die
fallzahlen angestiegen sind
sachsen anhalt hat noch ferien hier
beginnt am 27
august die schule das land will nur zwei
tage maske vorschreiben danach sollen
die schulen selbst entscheiden
das domgymnasium in magdeburg geht auf
nummer sicher zwei wochen masken pflicht
auch im unterricht sind bereits
angekündigt
es ist natürlich eine erhebliche
belastung wenn während des unterrichts
ständig mehrere stunden am tag maske
tragen getragen werden muss das werden
wir dann sehen aber das kann erst mal
kein grund sein darauf zu verzichten
in schleswig-holstein läuft die schule
wieder die masten pflicht auf dem
schulgelände gilt aber erst ab montag
mehrere lehrer hatten gegen den
präsenzunterricht geklagt scheiterten
damit jedoch gestern vor gericht
das gericht gestern ausgeführt haben wir
leben eben nicht in eine null
risikogesellschaft nirgendwo und das
gilt auch für den raum schule und unter
diesen bedingungen gelingt es uns jetzt
bildung tatsächlich den vorrang
einzuräumen
der anfang ist gemacht die
bewährungsprobe aber ob diese maßnahmen
reichen steht noch aus frankreich kämpft
mit erheblich steigt in corona zahlen
und es zeigt sich wieder wie sehr das
virus auch ein schlaglicht wirft auf
generelle missstände und soziale
ungleichheit innerhalb von 24 stunden
fast 4800 registrierten neuinfektionen
die schwelle von 50 neuansteckungen pro
100.000 einwohner innerhalb von einer
woche ist in sechs départements
überschritten auch im großraum paris und
abstand halten ist gerade in sozialen
brennpunkten dort eine herausforderung
freiraum oft ein luxusgut in den
vororten
die lage dort ist besonders schwierig
wie anna falls zeigt kommen für die
gesundheit so sollen die bewohner einer
hochhaussiedlung in einem vorort von
paris auf die straße gelockt werden
seit corona trauen sich viele bewohner
kaum mehr vor die tür gehen nur zum
einkaufen kurz raus und dann sofort
zurück ich bleibe nicht lange draußen
norisbank die algerierin fühlt sich wie
viele hier dem virus schutzlos
ausgeliefert beengte wohnverhältnisse
kaum zugang zu medizinischer versorgung
das will diese aktion ändern
ich wollte fragen wegen des testes ich
habe gehört der soll so weh tun wenn er
kommen sie mit mir mit mein kollege ist
krankenpfleger er kann ihn alles
erklären
die aufklärung ist längst überfällig
seit dem virus ist die sterberate für
menschen mit afrikanischen wurzeln um
bis zu 114 prozent angestiegen
ihre erste priorität ist nicht die
gesundheit ihm geht es ums essen darum
wie man die familie ernährt bekommt und
darum papiere zu haben um zu arbeiten
auch deshalb hat das virus hier eine
solche wucht entwickelt in dem viertel
gab es die meisten cupid 19 toten im
gesamten pariser großraum auch in ihrer
wohneinheit gab es tote und es waren
keine risikopatienten
das ist schlimm für mich es hat kleine
kinder getroffen nicht nur die alten
leute das wollen die aufklärer dieses
mal unbedingt verhindern
deshalb werden sie die aktion fortsetzen
masken verteilen zum test mehr ermutigen
und den bewohnern zeigen wie man das
virus in schach halten kann und jetzt
nochmal zurück in die usa in kalifornien
kämpfen die menschen mit gewaltigen wald
und buschbränden und das deutlich früher
im jahr als üblich viele verschiedene
feuer wüten etwa rund um san francisco
mindestens vier menschen sind bereits
ums leben gekommen mehr als 10.000
feuerwehrleute versuchen irgendwie
menschen und häuser zu retten und das
gelingt nicht immer an seinem stern
hier ist alles verloren ein ganzes zu
hause brennt nieder
die flammen in kalifornien haben eine
enorme kraft sie kommen immer wieder mit
großer geschwindigkeit
hunderte gebäude für immer zerstört auch
das haus von carroll nördlich von san
francisco
hier stand einmal ihre küche ich habe so
etwas noch nicht gesehen
der ganze himmel war rot dann kam das
feuer es kam über den hügel dort und es
war riesig
herren konnte sich rechtzeitig retten im
ganzen bundesstaat sind aktuell
zehntausende menschen auf der flucht vor
den flammen
ich mache mir wirklich sorgen wenn es in
den nächsten tagen so weiter brennt habe
ich bald kein zuhause mehr
die feuer wohl ausgelöst durch eine
serie von blitzeinschlägen
es ist extrem trocken hier experten
zufolge auch wegen des klimawandels
perfekte bedingungen für die flammen
tag und nacht sind die feuerwehrleute am
kämpfen gegen die vielen kleinen und
großen brandherde in kalifornien
es ist viel los hier
das corona virus und die hitzewelle
stromausfälle und jetzt das feuer aber
wir sind hart im nehmen wir werden
durchhalten durchhalten nicht einfach
bei so vielen gefährlichen krisen auf
einmal bilder aus kalifornien immer
wieder kalifornien jetzt mal ein schnitt
in der sendung und du machst du sport
genau noch zwei mal schlafen dann gilt
sonntagabend showdown in lissabon um
europas fußballkrone bayern münchen will
zum sechsten mal champions league
gewinner werden und dafür muss gegen
paris san remo vor allem auch bayerns
kapitän hellwach sein
trotz aller offensivstärke der bayern
gegen die pfeilschnellen stürmer aus
paris könnte der mann des tages auch
bayern torhüter neuer werden wenn man
vor manuel neuer eine
eins-gegen-eins-situation hat das ist
natürlich schon auch was anderes für ein
stürmer denn da weiß man da hat man es
mit einem wenn ich den besten torwart
der welt zu tun
er selbst hat es 2001 beim vorletzten
champions league triumph der bayern
vorgemacht im elfmeterschießen parierte
kam gegen valencia gleich drei schüsse
vom punkt sollte die bayern-abwehr im
finale so einfach wie hier im
viertelfinale gegen barcelona
ausgehebelt werden könnte also die große
stunde von manuel neuer schlagen und
diesen hochkarätigen fußball gipfel um
den begehrten henkelpott können sie live
ihr bei uns im zdf sonntagabend von 20
uhr 15 ansehen
ein finale das ein spannendes
offensivspektakel werden kann denn der
französische meister aus paris setzt
natürlich auch sein star duo nema und
dem papier
die teuersten spieler der welt
der 428 millionen euro angriff von
thomas tuchel die schnellste offensiv
kette der welt auf ihr ruhen die
hoffnungen von paris eine echte
herausforderung für die bayern abwehr
denn toren ist es auch gelungen aus
individualisten ein großartiges team zu
formen mit dem hunger zu gewinnen mit
der lust aufs verteidigen mit der auch
mit einer gewissen besessenheit die
dinge auf unsere seite zu zwingen mit
einer verbissenheit paris nur auf den
angriff zu reduzieren wäre falsch zwar
hat psg keinen manuel neuer
dennoch bietet paris die beste defensive
der laufenden champions-league-saison
wie es insgesamt nur fünf gegentore zu
ein großes finale auf augenhöhe mit den
bayern
tuchel und das projekt bsc stehen kurz
vor der krönung vor den ersten champions
league gewinnen
sie verlangen jetzt schon herrlich
christin heute noch mal eine echte
sommernacht also ich freue mich aber wem
das alles zu heiß ist der kann sie auch
freuen
da ist nämlich eine kaltfront auf dem
weg details gleich von katja honnefer
den blick auf die nachrichten übernimmt
bettina schausten im heute journal um 22
uhr und morgen ist an dieser stelle
petra gerster für sie da ich sage danke
für das interesse und von uns allen im
team 19 machen sie sich einen angenehmen
freitagabend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren wenn ihnen
das heute viel zu heiß war dann freuen
sie sich bestimmt über die kaltfront die
ja heute schon hier im westen regen
brachte
jetzt gibt's eine kleine regenpause die
es über wirklich nur von kurzer dauer
denn über frankreich bruders bereits
schon und diese regenschauer und
gewitter ziehen im laufe der nacht
weiter nach nordosten in der zweiten
nachthälfte erreichen sie bereits
thüringen später dann auch in sachsen
anhalt und zum frühen morgen auch berlin
und brandenburg diese kaltfront wird
morgen über tag deutschland ostwärts
verlassen am längsten schüttet es in
baden-württemberg in bayern und in
sachsen und im nordwesten kommen auch
wieder gewittrige regenfälle auf
dazwischen aber bleibt viel platz für
die sonne heute nacht gibt es nochmal
eine tropische nacht zumindest mal am
oberrhein und in magdeburg berlin und
dresden mit 21 bis 20 grad und morgen
wird vier kinder als heute
die höchstwerte liegen zwischen 22 und
28 grad und am sonntag erwarten uns dann
sogar nur noch 19 bis 25 grad an den
alpen und im nordwesten kann es einige
regenschauer und gewitter geben was uns
aber am meisten interessiert ist
natürlich die zdf übertragung des
champions league finales in lissabon
wenn da um 21 18 die sonne untergegangen
sein wird funkeln die sterne bei 21 grad
schönes wochenende